[Musique]
la commission de discipline a décidé de
suspendre l'ensemble des scores du score
jusqu'à la fin de la saison
moi je suis né à ses ongles vous avez
une idée pourquoi pas faire une équipe
de filles pour je l'espère derniers
matchs et joueuses tu te fous de ma part
qu'on a déjà vu des mecs jouer contre
des filles soit en foot qui seraient
volontaires mois
huawei il écoute les conversations monde
a les mains sur le bassin et on tombe
vois ça comme si on faisait du ou la
croatie ces exercices on n'est pas au
club med
oui là dimanche on aura des bonnes âmes
en face de nous il faut mettre 6 12 et
puis ce serait super thé temps la
machine avec messi a tout misé sur les
post it rien compris mais là tu étais où
quitter jusqu'au coup de bol en football
tu sais le truc que tu m'emmènes femme
dimanche sans me demander mon avis ben
moi je vous garantis que vous prenez je
vous le rappelle se croit
c'est combien comme ça qu'a eu des
bonnes choses
c'est votre premier match vous
connaissez pas encore
ça va progresser je veux pas nous lâcher
on a commencé ensemble finissent
ensemble on a besoin toile
marco au nom de toutes les filles je
tenais vraiment à remercier sa toile
grâce à vous les filles on vit comme des
choses exceptionnelles
je suis en espagne
ce qui se passe rien on ferme tout goûté
chez tous deux partout
[Musique]